después de que lo autorizara el gobierno
nacional el gobierno de la ciudad de
buenos aires- permitió a los locales de
gastronomía volver a atender a sus
clientes siempre y cuando sea en el
exterior con separación entre las mesas
y no más de cuatro personas por mesa
como parte del protocolo esto después de
más de cinco meses de cuarentena en
argentina es un alivio para el sector
gastronómico y también para los clientes
que estaban queriendo muchos volver a
salir a tomar oa comer algo fuera de sus
casas felicidad plenas después de muchos
meses muy feliz contenta es como volver
a la vida volver a vivir de nuevo
el lugar tomaba vida nuevamente de a
poquito despacito pero si es una alegría
inmensa pero más allá del alivio que
esto representa para el sector
gastronómico y sus clientes la medida
llega en un momento en que hay un gran
incremento de casos y muertes por kobe
19 en argentina de hecho el gobierno de
la provincia de buenos aires decidió que
en el conurbano bonaerense que es la
zona que rodea a la ciudad de buenos
aires no se abran los locales de
gastronomía de la misma forma que aquí
en la ciudad y nada quita de hecho que
en el futuro si empeora la situación la
propia ciudad dé marcha atrás con esta
medida